und wo wir gerade beim artenschutz sind
wie läuft es eigentlich bei den insekten
wir erinnern uns die werden rapide
weniger deshalb sollte eigentlich eine
überarbeitete ein neues lieblingswort
pflanzenschutzmittel anwendungs
verordnung noch in diesem jahr dafür
sorgen dass vielleicht mal weniger
insekten ab nippeln das war der plan hat
aber nicht richtig geklappt wenigstens
gibt es wohl bald einen fördertopf für
landwirte die neue technik einsetzen die
einsparung an pflanzenschutzmitteln
ermöglicht trotzdem liebe kinder folgt
nun eine ganz besonders traurige folge
von biene maja mit till reiners
[Musik]
hallo kinder möchte die biene maja ja
unsere regierung auch und deshalb haben
umwelt- und landwirtschaftsministerin
zusammen ein insektenschutz programm
beschlossen toll deutschland die neue
wellness oase für bienen was der bienen
schadet muss vermerk wenn es der biene
schlecht geht geht es der landwirtschaft
schlecht geht es der umwelt schlechten
dann geht es uns allen schlägers der
biene schadet das schadet auch uns
menschen wir müssen ein gespür dafür
haben wie es der biene geht ja nicht so
doll sagt mir mein gespür vor allem wild
bienensterben hier wie die fliegen und
sogar fliegen sterben wie die fliegen
unter anderem wegen glyphosat deswegen
hat das kabinett beschlossen wir sprühen
weniger glyphosat bevor es 2024 ganz
verboten wird das war vor 15 monaten
und dann hat das
landwirtschaftsministerium das gemacht
was es am besten kann
oder in den worten der umweltministerin
glück das ministerium habe zum
insektenschutz bislang folgendes
geliefert nichts
das ist nicht viel seit über anderthalb
jahren wird verzögert hoch die glöckner
ist die böse thekla in der geschichte
die hat nur so getan als hätte die die
biene lieb aber die liebt eigentlich die
bauern und die wiederum lieben glyphosat
sie was ist nur in konsequenz hat keine
toxische wirkung sie können live
vorträgen die basierte nix da passiert
nicht nur die sprache wird etwas könig
ist der reposatz wasser klar sterben
einzelne bienen wenn sie nicht hart
genug sind andere dinge stehen auf die
vorfahrt für das ist quasi eine droge
die junkies fliegen direkt unter den
luftdüsen her und endstation ist dann
leider oft anschaffen auf dem ameisen
straßenstrich glyphosat ist
wahrscheinlich krebserregend sagt die
whu und was sagen wir deutschen wenn
etwas wahrscheinlich krebserregend ist
okay dann dürft ihr das eben nur noch
vier jahre versprühen
immerhin hat glück das ministerium einen
coolen wettbewerb ausgelobt wer schützt
die bienen freiwillig sie sind gefragt
wir suchen vor bildern zeigen sie uns
wie insekten freundlich sie erreichen
das agrarministerium auf jeden fall
nicht gute idee auch für andere
ministerien die bundeswehr hat keine
funktionierenden panzer welcher bürger
bastelt und seinen aus reichelsheim wir
immer noch kein endlager für atommüll
hat vielleicht jemanden abschließbaren
keller den er nicht mehr braucht nicht
genug impfstoff einfach abspritzen jetzt
mitmachen zu gewinnen gibt's immer
[Musik]
kleine durch wechselbäder war
er stößt sich meyer
mal
[Musik]
was denn über meinen arsch geigensolo
war doch versprochen
ihr könnt ja in der zeit den kanal
abonnieren
[Musik]